you always give such sage advice to
everyone else and I'm just curious as
you look over your life what advice
would you give to seven-year-old Oprah
or 30-member
about surviving as a woman in this world
7 I was so sad and at 7 all of my real
love came from my teachers and so my
teachers I would say this to anybody in
this room you have no idea of the power
of noticing another human being and what
it feels like when somebody knows that
they have been seen truly seen by you it
is the greatest offering you can give
and all those years of the Oprah show
the greatest lesson I learned was that
you know after every show someone would
say invariably in one way or another how
is that I finish an interview with
father who killed his twin daughters I
finish an interview with politician
Barack Obama Joe Biden George Bush they
Beyonce they all say the same thing how
was that and so I started to see that
there's this common thread in our
humanity where everybody wants to know
how was that did I do okay did you hear
me and did what I say means something to
you so I would have to say that
recognizing that in other people has
helped me to become you know a person of
compassion a personal understanding
person who can interview anybody about
anything because I know that it the core
of you is the same as core me you just
want to be heard so yes Oprah directly
actually Oprah directly in front of you
directly directly so GMA Philippines
last year when Meryl Streep won this
award I felt a very different time Trump
had just won we had all the allegations
last year with your speech with everyone
in you know solidary solidarity and
black tonight do you feel like the
country together as a whole is moving in
a better direction than we moved last
year I certainly feel that what
you know I always think and no having
watched it over the years through
thousands and thousands of interviews
and watching people in their dysfunction
that when something really negative is
brewing that there is the direct
opposite reaction that is also possible
because for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction
so when something is big as what started
to happen in October with Harvey
Weinstein started to unfold I thought
whoa whoa whoa and with every day's
revelation I thought here is an
opportunity for something powerfully a
powerful growth and how do we use this
moment to elevate what is happening
instead of victim continually victimize
ourselves and so I think that wearing
black in solidarity is one step I think
that what time's up is doing with a
Legal Defense Fund is a major step was
very important to all of us involved
with times up that it not just be about
the women of Hollywood because we're
already a privileged group but to extend
to the women of the world because as I
said tonight there isn't a culture a
race a religion a politic a workplace
that hasn't been affected by it and one
of the reasons why I wanted to tell resi
Taylor's story is to let people know
it's been happening for a very long time
when people didn't feel that they could
speak up and so there are so many women
who've endured so much and remained
silent and kept going because there was
no other recourse and now that we've all
joined as one voice I think that those
it is feels like empowerment to those
women who never had
it